with confirmed cases of kovat 19
increasing at an exponential rate the
entire planet is in the throes of its
most serious pandemic disease in a
century
ghovat 19 has already changed our way of
life in the US and the situation is
likely to get worse before it gets
better
Hollywood has been predicting this kind
of event for a long time and viewers are
turning to films such as outbreak in
contagion on streaming services to
perhaps make some sense of the new
normal on day one there were two people
and then and then 16 max Brooks is one
right so who's been thinking about
pandemic disease in the context of his
creative work for years
in a recent reddit AMA the World War Z
author offered his take on how the
current real-life coronavirus crisis
compares to the zombie outbreak
portrayed in his famous work World War Z
the novel was turned into the 2013 Brad
Pitt movie of the same name
and the source material is credited with
providing an accurate and well
researched account of how an
uncontrolled pandemic might spread stuff
to fuss pathologist from Harvard the
analogy I keep coming back to is Spanish
flu Brooks was cautious not to equate
cope in 19 with a zombie pathogen that
brought the world to its knees in a
seminal work with that in mind he still
considers the current crisis a wake-up
call for a world ill equipped to manage
a serious pandemic he wrote I think the
corona virus is as dangerous as we allow
it to be this is not the end of the
world but we need to take it seriously
implement measures to curb the spread
marshal the resources of government and
industry behind a vaccine and treatment
as regular citizens we need to think
about what we can do social distancing
washing hands avoiding crowds and for
God's sake stay home if you're sick we
can't just think about can I get it we
need to think about who can I infect we
have the power to turn this around but
we need to make the right choices that
all sounds a lot like the
recommendations coming out of the World
Health Organization and its domestic
counterpart a Center for Disease Control
but Brooks realized in the course of
researching World War Z is that human
beings tend to be slow to rally and
institutional response to a threat like
kovat 19 as depicted in his book which
country sent to take their public health
for granted this can lead to situations
like what's unfolding in Italy or the
measures outlined by Brooks are intended
to mitigate the spread of the disease at
home as a means of flattening the curve
and reducing the impact on our soon to
be over
and health care system published back in
2006 Brooks novelist subtitled an oral
history of the zombie war historian
falls through a series of interviews and
first-hand accounts of the people on the
front lines of the outbreak this
backward-looking framing device lends a
retrospective tone that's unusual for a
thriller as if Brooks is presenting a
planet's collective recollection of an
existential disaster one of the most
salient features of World War Z is the
implied warning to world governments not
to downplay the threat of a pandemic on
reddit Brooks expressed his hope that
the US government doesn't take the same
head in sand approach that he depicts in
his book the personal stakes are high
for Brooks his father film and comedy
legend Mel Brooks is 93 and in the
highest-risk demographic the serious
complications should he contract kovat
19 I'll probably be okay but if I give
it to him he could give it to Carl
Reiner who could give it to Dick Van
Dyke and before I know it I've wiped out
a whole generation of comedic legends
Brooks wrote on reddit's I have to be
very careful about infecting my father
that's why I've canceled some
appearances and might possibly have to
pivot my whole book tour to a virtual
tour right now I'm preparing to my son's
school to be closed I think about my dad
and my mother-in-law who's had lung
cancer twice and all the vulnerable
people in my life I could infect if I'm
not careful even if we're not members of
the highest-risk demographic let's take
a cue from Brooks and practice good
hygiene to protect our vulnerable
friends family and neighbors from the
coronavirus
[Music]